Thanks so yeah this talk is do read
errors matter for DNA assembly um
unfortunately you don't have to know
anything about DNA or anything about
assembly in order to follow this talk
just kind of a cute combinatorial
problem i think that i became interested
in over the last year and so I figured I
talked about that okay so that's a read
error yes this is the illustration of
the topic for today ok ok and then I
should mention that this is joint work
with elan show Maroni coincidentally
gave a very similar talk last week we
didn't coordinate very well in advance
and David ok so the general idea behind
DNA assembly is starts with DNA
sequencing and basically what you have
is you have a very long sequence which
is unknown to you and this guy is just
composed of like a C's T's and G's and
current technology doesn't allow us to
just read the bases off of the sequence
directly so basically what happens is
you can imagine getting short fragments
of this sequence so maybe when I draw a
box here it means that I basically lift
the string from down here call this a
gtc t also be like AG TCT ok and I get a
whole bunch of these short fragments and
these guys are called reads and they
come from basically random positions
with respect to the original sequence
and I get a lot of them
so for the purposes of this talk will
just assume they are all the same length
length L okay and I'll say in reads ok
so your goal is to take basically a
basket filled with these reads these
short fragments and then your goal is to
somehow put them all together and try
and determine what this underlying
sequences that would have generated
these these reeds ok so this sequence
just to give you an idea length gee
sorry I can't see that over there ok so
the sequence of this or the length of
this underlying sequence here is G base
pair is long and so it's a really large
jigsaw puzzle because G even for
bacteria is something like order of
millions of base pairs long and for
humans it's say order of billions of
base pairs long so you get a whole bunch
of reads of say length 200 base pairs or
maybe a few thousand base pairs and your
goal is to assemble them completely ok
so there's kind of two ways of answering
or trying to address this problem and
the first might be more from a computer
science perspective that says ok so
suppose I give you a whole bunch of
these substrings give me an efficient
algorithm for say producing the shortest
super string that contains all of them
as substrings now another way of looking
at this problem is maybe more of an
information-theoretic viewpoint ok so
information theoretic question here
might be of the form for what values of
n L
can we unambiguously reconstruct this
underlying sequence s okay so actually
quite a bit is known about this in
particular I think about plotting l and
I'll call it the coverage depth which is
just n x over G so what is this this is
just the average number of times each
base is covered all right ok so you can
come up with some pretty simple bounds
here so there's something called the
lander Waterman coverage depth bound
which says that if these reeds are taken
at random positions you basically need a
certain number in order to guarantee
that every single base is covered if you
if you don't do that you have no prayer
of reconstructing right ok and then in
the other dimension in the read length
there's another number here which I'll
leave as a mystery for this talk but
it's just a critical read length that
depends on the sequence the actual
definition is not important for this
talk so i won't go into it and basically
above this you can below this you won't
be able to reproduce the sequence
there'll be two sequences where you
could essentially shift parts around and
and so there would be some ambiguity and
then we know actually from some recent
work by breslar breslar and Shay in 2013
they actually showed that empirically
anyways I mean they have a proof of an
upper bound and lower bound and you can
evaluate this curve for particular
sequences empirically the real line
looks like this where we can reconstruct
and
reconstruct down please no so this is
okay so let me give you the lay of the
land here so sequence model so you could
model this underlying sequence s here
and I think this is what your question
was you can model it as say an iid
sequence or something like that or what
you could do is you could take the say
deterministic sequence or individual
sequence model where the sequence is
just a given sequence okay so this will
be individual sequence model and then
maybe in this dimension we could write
read errors ? and then no and yes
basically this is where this breslin
Bresler shape paper fits in okay so
that's this curve here for individual
sequence and but there's no errors in
the reeds basically these these
fragments that are given to you have no
ambiguity I mean they're taken directly
from the the underlying sequence so
there also is yeah so so that's what
this the assumption here is that
basically the reeds you choose a
position uniformly at random and then
the reed is taken as at length L sub
string that follows so so if all the
reads repetitions of the same letter a
yeah and you wouldn't be able to leave
exactly so actually that's where this
okay so so one assumption may be that i
glossed over here is will assume that
this length of the underlying sequence
is known that's not realistic in
practice but in practice we actually
have an estimate of how long the
sequence might be so just think that we
know the length of the sequence and
we're trying to determine what exactly
that sequences but you raise a good
point
that if a lot of my reads look the same
I mean for instance take l equals one in
which case all of my reads are going to
be a C's GS and T's I'm certainly not
going to be able to reproduce the
sequence right I mean we can we can
agree on that point so that's what this
critical read length depends on actually
is the is a repetition structure of this
underlying sequence and that's actually
why it's important to consider the
individual sequence model because in iid
sequence model has very short repeat
repeated sequences right so it turns out
that this that kind of the statistic
that determines is critical read length
depends on the that repetition structure
critically I'm pretty mean it's we soak
until you succeed no so this is like a
with high probability result essentially
this no no so so in the individual
sequence model right the the sequence
length is fixed right and so basically
you're looking in in the number of reads
so this is normalized or basically
coverage depth right and so as long as
you get a certain amount of of coverage
I mean so if you take a random number or
a number of reads then you can guarantee
that a certain fraction of the sequence
will be covered with high probability
right or the whole sequence will be
covered with high probability so that's
basically the with high probability you
need some positive yeah so it's your
perimeter said respect to end
no no I agree so I guess what basically
this this coverage depth would depend on
say your error probability okay does
that make sense right yeah okay yeah so
the individual sequence model is that
this sequence the underlying sequence
that you are getting these reads from is
fixed we don't know it but it's just a
fixed sequence okay we don't make any
sarcastic assumptions about it it's just
a fixed sequence so actually following
up on Jake's question so I mean what if
they were just you know you had all a's
and then followed by all c's I mean
could you write how could you hope to
reproduce that sequence right well then
certainly you would need a read length
that's long enough to allow you to
disambiguate kind of how long this
repetition is right so if I have a
sequence that's we're getting a little
bit far afield but that's okay doesn't
mean the vertical dotted line will be
more to the right you'll be more to the
right as i said this depends on the the
repeat structure of the sequence so here
i can imagine like basically this set of
C's is repeated here and it's also
repeated here right so it's going to be
very long so it's going to demand that
we have a very long read length which
will effectively bridge this whole
string of C's in order to help us or
guarantee that we'll be able to
reproduce the sequence okay so what I'm
going to talk about today though is
there's no with high probabilities so
that will satisfy your point okay so let
me just point out that there's a few
other works here the iid sequence model
so there's some work by motihari breslar
and Shay also in 13
earlier some work by you Conan and
pepsin sorry that's okay it's like 9d1 i
think in 95 then here is a Mata Hari Ram
Chandra and Shey and ma also 13 and so
today is here where we're considering
individual sequence model but with read
errors okay so let me know describe
exactly the setting so our setting will
consider is a so called dense read model
basically what this means is i have have
a read at every position okay so
basically i have my sequence s here
in my reads are just taken at every
single position in this sequence so have
G reads and we assume that this sequence
is cyclic so to avoid edge effects a
read taken say at the very end here will
wrap around and connect over there ok ok
so this is a dense remodel so what does
this mean it means we're operating way
up in this regime here right where we
just have maximum coverage and so really
this is kind of the the regime that
we're looking at we're trying to
determine this asymptote essentially ok
now our error model is adversarial
erasers a trait
I / l so what is it what exactly does
that mean my read lengths are of length
L so what I'm going to allow an
adversary to do is erase at most D
positions / read okay something like
this so the erasers or read and then
there's another constraint here which is
if I look and I have a read every single
position how many reads cover a single
base in this underlying sequence exactly
oh right right and so what we also do is
we restrict the adversary to put at most
D ratios per base right so this is
consistent with the error rate to do ver
el sol de ratios
base okay so that's the basic idea so
let me just introduce some notation RL s
equals set of dense length and then
we'll just right r SE el deeb s equals
erased
great so the basic picture is this is
that I have my sequence goes through a
sequencer outcomes my reads then my
adversary corrupt some what I'm left
with at the end of the day is a whole
bunch of reads with the whole bunch of
erasers and the question is how can I
assemble these to put them back together
in a sequence there's a setting clear
everybody okay so actually going through
this we realize that the question that
we should be asking is not when can I
reconstruct the original sequence but
what can I do in terms of correcting
this set of reeds so this introduces the
notion of so this time is sometimes
called the el spectrum basically what it
is is it's the relative frequency of
length L strings that are peering in the
sequence so this introduces the notion
of spectrum error
basically what I'd like to do is take my
corrupted set of reads spectrum error
correction to produce an uncorrupted set
of reads of shorter lengths so if you
can imagine if my adversary is very lazy
right and basically they take all the
reads and they always just delete the
last d positions of them then what i can
do is i can take this corrupted spectrum
right and i can produce an uncorrupted
spectrum where l prime equals L minus D
for instance because the last dr just
raced right so so but that's only if I
have a very lazy adversary and so kind
of the main result here is that we can
actually do spectrum error correction
you
even under this adversarial model so let
me write down the result and i don't
think i'll actually is that um if Oh
so I need to define what this quantity
is but let me explain the result first
and then I'll define exactly what it is
then and correct
so the only thing that I didn't define
here is what exactly is this okay which
I'll tell you about in just a second so
what does this result say basically it
says that if my read okay so as a simple
example maybe this aside for a second if
so take a equals L print if L greater
than
okay so as a corollary basically if I
take K equals my critical read length
that would be needed for the
reconstruction in the air free case
basically if my read length is greater
than that critical length plus D times
some multiplier here which for now just
think of it as a small number it's going
to be like 23 then basically what I'm
able to do is clean up that spectrum and
then assemble the sequence so let me
define exactly what this MV is so as we
discussed the L critical is a function
of kind of the repeats in in the
underlying sequence right so this M is
actually another measure of kind of the
repeat structure of this underlying
sequence so n s is defined to be the
maximum number of repeats
okay so basically what i mean is i have
my sequence s here and if i look at say
a bunch of sub sequences x2 x3 so on and
so forth and let's say that these guys
aren't exactly alike but maybe what the
adversary could do is erase d positions
from each of these and make them look
like it came from some sequence X right
so they aren't exact repeats but their d
approximate in the sense that there's
some centroid and so basically it's a
have these points x1 x2 x3 and by D
approximate repeats I mean that they lie
in a ball of radius D right so basically
what this what this does is it captures
the approximate repeats I guess so this
was
faster than me
it won't be exists with these segments
Vegas jump in just in the future all
right just in the picture they're
disjoint they could be actually
overlapping I just want to give kind of
the idea how this works actually there's
less time than I thought there was which
made me rush through quite quickly I
think I got a little bit I would have
order here okay so basically how does
this work so what I want to do is I want
to show that if my let's say what I do
is I take these erased reads and I
assemble them into some sequence s hat
right so this basically is I built this
by putting all these raced reads on here
maybe these guys have some ratios in
them but what I'm able to do is
depending on how they line i correct in
and build the sequence s head so if I
want to show the spectrum error
correction result what I need to show is
that basically every these guys are of
length L every sequence of length K plus
one that appears in my reconstructed
sequence should also appear in my
original sequence right
and so basically let this corresponds to
is if I think about listing all the sub
sequences of length K or sub strings of
length K + 1 in s hat so let's say s hat
one up to k plus 1 s hat to up to k plus
2 so on so forth
the bipartite graph here I list all the
sub strings of length K + 1 and ass and
in this bipartite graph i connect
vertices if they're equal right and the
first thing that we notice is that this
bipartite graph any connected component
is a completely connected component
right because if this equals this equals
this equals this well clearly that also
has to be equal right so in order to
show this result that basically the k
plus 1 spectrum of the sequence i
reproduced equals the k plus 1 spectrum
of this original sequence corresponds
are just showing that there's a perfect
matching in each of these connected
components right so for that it's just
essentially haal sune
and so the basic idea behind this you
can probably see how it goes just
basically follow our nose and use the
properties that we have here and we say
okay well let's look at where all these
Reed's go let's say this Reed originally
came from here in s and maybe this Reed
also came from here in s and then this
read maybe came from here and this Reed
came from over here and all I need to do
is look at basically where this section
is in each of these guys
so that's there this guy's may be here
this guy let's say is here if i call
this sequence X this X 1 X 2 so on and
so forth up to X M well by the
constraint on the adversary right that I
can release mo too steep positions these
guys are all within distance D of this X
yeah so basically there's at most M as
dlf of these guys or k plus 1 sorry I
know how many reads cover this sequence
so II treat of is of length L this the
length of x is k plus 1 so basically
there's L minus K reads that completely
contain this guy by that inequality is
greater than D times ms k plus 1 right
so just by pigeonhole principle now
there's got to be at least one of these
guys that has greater than D reads
sitting on them and by the that kind of
vertical constraint on my adversary it
allows me to completely correct all
those all those errors right so that's a
case a equals one and then the other
case requires or more generally it's the
it's the same interest requires more
bookkeeping but basically kind of for us
anyway it was kind of interesting to
think of instead of trying to do error
correction and reconstruct the whole
sequence really what we can always do is
just kind of you know abandon really
trying to reconstruct the sequence and
we can always reconstruct a smaller
spectrum that's completely error-free
and so it kind of makes sense if you
think in the extreme case i can always
reconstruct the one spectrum it's just a
C's GS and T's essentially but then in
it in for like larger k right it's it's
it's non-trivial and so a few things
about tightness in fact we don't know
how tight this would be in general but
we do have examples where this is tight
where we can construct sequences that
that
is the best that you can do and then as
I said we evaluated this guy for several
real genomes and it turns out to be a
relatively small multiplier so so really
do you read or do read errors affect DNA
assembly and the answer is well increase
your read lengths by maybe you know
fifty percent in the worst case but but
it's not like an order of magnitude blow
up or anything like that so another
thing that kind of comes out of this is
presently in practice the way that error
correction is done in assembly is it's
kind of a separation based approach as
an information theorist would say
basically what they do is they cluster
all the reads and then they try to do
error correction that way so then they
assemble based on kind of the assumption
that they have a clean set of reads
whereas here it's not a very construct
it's not a constructive scheme because
we don't tell you how you should
assemble these erased reads but what
it's saying is that you should do kind
of the error correction and the assembly
jointly so one final comment if we do so
so we might say now that there is some
okay if L greater than mean okay so this
guy maybe we might call I'll Tilda
critical so if my read length exceeds
this guy then I'm guaranteed to be able
to reconstruct a sequence but it's a
little bit funky if you think about it
because it says I'm I read length needs
to be longer than some function of the
sequence that I don't have right but
actually it's not too hard to see that
there is an implied certificate property
here that if I reconstruct s hat say an
l is greater than L print which I can
compute because I basically constructed
this guy so basically you can do your
sequencing assemble and then check and
certify whether you got the correct
answer or not and this is all under like
adversarial errors and in what not as
well so that's it
and anything real their decision yeah so
actually we believe that just kind of
like similar to a coding theory type of
result where you can handle substitution
errors that would have the rate of
ratios we believe that you should
basically just stick it to here for
substitution errors in fact we thought
we had a proof of that but then we found
a small bug but we believe that it
should still hold and we think that we
can actually resolve what we have so yes
not yet I can't say anything formally on
the record but but I believe that it
works out to be essentially the same the
real problem is is that in in sequencing
the types of errors that are predominant
are not necessarily substitutions or
erasers but insertions and deletions
which are kind of a whole nother animal
so I mean the good news is that very
little has been done on a theoretical
side of sequencing in the presence of
errors so it Richards is kind of a very
first step but certainly we have kind of
a long way to go but I think it's more
about trying to get intuition about
whether the air significantly affect the
read length required or not yeah
essentially the number bodacious 50 and
put a face to say
it's not essential so actually you could
put you know things would change
slightly I think if you said like D
errors / read and then be Sadie one
errors / / read and then d two errors
per cone then one of these becomes D 1
and 1 becomes D 2 I think and that's it
but the basic idea is that we have like
a racial rate of D over L the idea is to
try and somehow model random errors
right which you would expect would
happen at kind of a uniform rate we have
a different model where we consider like
windowed errors so any window of a
particular length when we considered it
only contains a certain number of
erasers and then this actually becomes
much better this is a pretty pessimistic
no questions
people let's back tom